al'annonce par les médias américains de
la victoire de joe biden de nombreux
chefs d'état se sont empressés de lui
envoyer un message de félicitations ce
qui n'a pas encore été le cas de
vladimir poutine et son porte parole
explique de façon très simple le kremlin
attend la proclamation officielle des
résultats
nous considérons approprié d'attendre le
bilan officiel des élections
nous vous rappelons que le président
poutine a déclaré à plusieurs reprises
qu'il respecterait le choix du peuple
américain quel qu'il soit qu'il serait
prêt à travailler avec n'importe quel
président élu des etats unis
dans tous les cas nous espérons pouvoir
établir un dialogue avec le prochain
président des états unis d'amérique
élaborée conjointement des moyens pour
normaliser nos relations bilatérales
d'autant plus qu'une partie importante
de ses relations bilatérales il s'agit
ici du domaine de la stabilité
stratégique et de la sécurité ne
concerne pas seulement nos deux peuples
mais tous les peuples du monde entier
pourtant il a quatre ans le président
russe avait rapidement félicité donald
trump
mais pour dimitri peskov la situation
est différente cette année
il y a quatre ans poutine a tout de
suite félicité trump pourquoi le kremlin
garde-t-il cette fois le silence
la différence est absolument évidente
certaines procédures juridiques ont été
annoncées par le président en fonction
voilà pourquoi la situation est cette
fois différente c'est pourquoi nous
estimons approprié d'attendre l'annoncé
officielle du résultat final la russie
n'est pas la seule dans ce cas là a
montré une certaine prudence la chine le
mexique ou encore le brésil attendent
aussi les résultats définitifs pour
prendre acte de la victoire de joe biden
mais il faut dire qu'avec ce nouveau
locataire à la maison blanche
moscou ne s'attend pas forcément à une
amélioration de ses relations avec
washington
durant la campagne électorale joe biden
avait désigné la russie comme menace
principale pour la sécurité des états
unis et du temps de l'administration
obama lorsqu'il était vice-président joe
biden s'était à de nombreuses reprises
montrées hostiles envers moscou
d'un autre côté il s'est récemment
montré ouvert au dialogue concernant les
différents traités de contrôle des
armements stratégiques des traités
dénoncer les uns après les autres par
donald trump
pour résumer patience et prudence sont
donc de mise du côté du kremlin